camping comme ce soir je reçois à
stéphane bern pour répondre à une
critique plutôt sévère de samuel gontier
de télérama mais pas une critique sur
stéphane bern l'acteur qui a joué deux
cent cinquante fois numéro
complémentaire ou sur stéphane bern
l'auteur qui publie chez flammarion un
si joli monde
mais stéphane bern l'animateur un
animateur d'une nouvelle émission
la reine de france sur france 2 stéphane
bern donc ce soir je suis ravi de vous
voir des livres écouter avec plaisir
avant de parler de cette émission un
grand d'entendre les douze parole de
samuel gontier
je crois quand même revenir sur ce livre
un si joli monde
il ya une très jolie citation d'oscar
wilde qui à mon avis dit beaucoup de
votre de votre projet faire partie de la
bonne société est une corvée
non pas faire partie est une tragédie et
c'est un peu ça l'idée c'est là je me
suis moqué évidemment de toutes les
impostures qu'on voit dans les
mondanités
pendant des années on me dit stéphane
bern le chroniqueur mondain c'est vrai
que je suis sorti un peu google voilà
comme beaucoup de gens et j'ai vu
beaucoup de gens formidables m'aider
beaucoup d' imposture
c'est l'histoire d'un chroniqueur
mondain qui naviguent là dedans c'est
mon histoire au début donc je me moque
aussi moi même c'est pour dire que j'ai
pas mal d'autodérision un clown
donc vous ne craignez pas de ne plus
être invité à certaines tables quand
bien même
très drôle bon alors voyons voir si vous
allez est invité à la table de télérama
donc de cette n'ont jamais été leur
tasse de thé un télérama il faut le dire
quand même déjà j'ai un délit de sale
gueule pour eux parce que trop lisse le
type qui j'ai fêté j'étais à tf1 vend
maintenant j'avais et puis péché et puis
j'étais demandé jeudi commercial du
sagas le mec de sa gamme à la bombe à
écouter alors on est parti bonjour
stéphane j'espère que vous allez bien je
viens vous parler de la reine de france
qui m'a beaucoup déçu et qui m'a
d'autant plus déçu que vous êtes
quelqu'un que j'aime bien que j'apprécie
et vous savez j'ai été vraiment atterré
par l'émission je crois malheureusement
c'est le mot qui convient j'étais
d'autant plus déçu que non seulement je
vous aime bien mais en plus vous avez
une certaine ambition pour cette
émission est en tout cas c'est ce que
vous avez dit dès le premier numéro que
vous alliez créer un espace de liberté
un espace de réflexion tels qu'il en
existait plus à la télévision depuis
très longtemps et malheureusement je
pense qu'en fait d' espace de réflexion
c'est plutôt un espace de cacophonie
d'invectivés d'anecdotes ou 20 ans je
peut interrompre comme ses soeurs ont
déjà c'est vrai que l'ambition était
fort de la première émission de la seule
qu'il ait vu avec bernard tapie c'est un
peu ça je lui donner raison
oui c'est l'accident on était dans le
spectaculaire mais encore une fois on
réforme dans la croissance comme ça
marchait bien je me suis dis arrêtons le
spectaculaire tout de suite et essayons
de creuser moi j'accepte la critique
la seule chose c'est ne me jugez pas sur
une émission jugée l'émission sur sa
longueur serre sur sur chaque semaine on
s'améliore on écoute on s'amuse j'ai
l'impression que c'est le dispositif qui
est très gênant parce qu'il est
pléthorique envahissant le dealer
esposito rick voilà une remarque que
j'ai entendu c'est vrai qu'il y avait
six invités d'un côté six invités de
l'autre les pour les contre ça ça
fonctionne bien mais si c'est trop oui
parce que au fond après trop de
dialogues tout le dialogue trop débattu
le débat il faut peut-être plus ciblée
essayer de trouver les arguments des
personnages qui sont beaucoup plus
emblématiques plus ciblées moins
spectaculaire encore une fois 5 c'est
largement suffisant
les interventions de la caméra cachée
qui vient cacher qu'il ne fait pas
tellement rire parce que c'est toujours
un faux policiers qui mènent ces caméras
cachées qui à chaque fois use et abuse
de son autorité et lui il est carrément
clairement dans l'arbitraire il le
revendique il la cultive et cultive
arbitraire mais alors ça c'est
évidemment c'est de l'humour
bon je comprends que ça puisse gêner
c'était le mélange des genres mais c'est
la vie c'est que quand vous discutez
vous avez un débat de société très
profond de vous poser des vraies
questions de temps en temps vous avez
besoin de ce resort de l'humour pour
dédramatiser
j'ai l'impression d'avoir vraiment il
est très charmant samuel bonnet mais
c'est vraiment la cabale des dévots et
des bien pensants mais ça m'étonne pas
de télérama en même temps il ya aussi
les interventions du intervention du
standard avec jean-claude du luxe dont
l'humour ne me fait pas vraiment rire
même au 18e congrès j'ai du mal à
comprendre j'ai du mal à admettre flirt
autant avec la avec le racisme souvent
la misogynie l'homophobie phr à sa train
attendait voilà c'est évidemment on fait
rire avec dvd des choses qui sont
violentes mais qui nous permettent de
nous interroger
j'ai du mal à penser que ce gonthier
plus et puis imaginez un instant qu'on
frise avec la démagogie l'homophobie le
racisme le racisme et la misogynie
nouveau en tout cas c'est mal le
connaître c'est comme ça que le racing
se développe
merci on ne peut plus enjoué ça veut
donc dire que notre démocratie est bien
malade
vous constatez qu'il ya un changement
dans ce domaine là on peut plus rire un
peu plus ré il ya vraiment des sujets
maintenant sur lequel on ne peut plus
rire on peut plus pour faire des blagues
sur les noirs il faut demander aux noirs
de le faire des blagues sur les juifs
aux demandes et aux juifs aux deux
barres sur les homos faut demander aux
homos pardon je suis pas tout à la fois
mais je veux bien faire des efforts il
ya aussi un invité un invité fil rouge
qui n'a pas grand chose à voir avec les
débats qui est michel serres jacques
attali faut que j'aie faut pas exagérer
non plus là pour vendre un livre un
disque ou un film ce qui n'est pas très
grave mais non justement
ils ne vendent plus en venant dans
l'émission le spectateur je pense est
perdue en tous cas nous ne sollicite pas
beaucoup son intelligence et on pourrait
dire que le slogan de la reine de france
et il est interdit de réfléchir
voilà ça me gêne que cette émission soit
sur le service public ça me va aussi
alors voilà ça c'est des trucs toujours
des quelque chose ne plaît pas on dit
c'est scandaleux sur le service public
et vous savez c est ce qui me tue de là
dedans c'est qu'on m'a dit la même chose
quand je suis arrivé à france inter
aujourd'hui on pense que je suis l'un
des piliers du service public
radiophonique
donc on peut pas tout me reprocher le
pour et le contre mais ce qui est
incroyable c'est un peu comme un match
de foot comme une équipe de foot où la
sélection française et on a l'impression
qu'il ya 62 millions de sélectionneurs
qui à 62 millions de français qui savent
ce qui est deux services publics et ce
qui ne l'est pas ça c'est l'argument qui
tue c'est après tout tous à vos idées
sympathiques berne son émission vaut ce
qu'elle vaut c'est à dire pas grand
chose mais surtout c'est pas de service
public arrive à décréter alors que
justement si je ne m'étais pas senti de
service public je ne serais jamais allé
dans cette aventure je suis pas idiot
non plus faire j'ai pas envie d'aller me
fourvoyer
j'ai au contraire le sentiment d'être
quelqu'un de profondément engagé j'ai
été un citoyen élu j'ai toujours je me
suis toujours investi dans la vie de la
cité
j'ai toujours considéré qu'on était sur
cette terre pour faire des choses en
tout cas pour éclairer pour pour donner
à réfléchir
c'est la pire des insultes qu'on puisse
me dire ces deux on interdit aux gens de
réfléchir c'est pas vrai
que ce soit vous stéphane m'bia
présentiez parce qu'il me semble que
vous êtes un bon interviewer vous êtes
quelqu'un que j'apprécie parce que vous
savez mettre les gens en confiance
il me semble que c'est ça ne représente
pas que c'est un peu de lentilles berne
j'aimerais bien que vous m'expliquiez
aussi quels ont été les buts que vous
avez voulu atteindre
à mon avis ils ne sont pas atteints sauf
peut-être au niveau de l'audience
puisque l affaire à moi j'ai le plus
petit que celui-ci n'est pas très
encourageant pour l'état de notre
démocratie
le public aura t'il temps non non le
public a suivi ça a très bien marché
quand c'est très spectaculaire
ça marche un petit peu moins bien mais
ça marche très bien
quand on sait moins spectaculaire donc
voila moi aussi je préfère gagner avec
du nom spectaculaire plutôt que de
d'avoir un plébiscite avec du
spectaculaire et donc je sais c'est je
pense que j'ai répondu en faisant je le
sent gêné de me dire tout ça je suis
assez touché parce que oui oui avec ayew
d'affection celui de gentillesse je
crois simplement pour lui répondre que
regarder les les émissions de la reine
de france depuis la première et vous
verrez que le chemin qu'on a parcouru
encore une fois j'ai essayé de modifier
un peu et dans mon comportement et dans
le dispositif ce qui n'allait pas en
tout cas avoir sa montre l'importance de
la critique côté constructif que peut
avoir des critiques et tout ce que vous
avez recommandé c'est d'aller voir les
nouvelles émissions de vous retrouver
sur france 2 c'est 3-1 mercredi par mois
en ce moment c'est plutôt 4 par mois
mais moi c'est en moyenne 3,4 mercredi
par mois mais encore une fois je
j'écoute les critiques
évidemment il ya eu une réaction
épidermique ses traits
on n'aime pas être être jugé durement
quand ça en plus quand ça quand on y
croit si vous voulez quand on y met tout
son coeur tout son travail tout son
temps et son âme mais c'est bien je je
je trouve cet exercice extrêmement bas
écoutez nous on a inauguré avec vous la
venue
d'un animateur de télévision pour
répondre à une critique vous avez donné
la preuve de l'intérêt de l'exercice en
tout cas nous il nous donne
comment ces derniers mots merci à samuel
gontier de wii en avoir eu le courage de
me le dire et j'ai écouté vos critiques
en tout cas moi je voudrais en parler de
votre livre un si joli monde et moi je
vois le mot roman et je me demande si
stéphane bern ne fait pas son entrée
dans le roman est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui non mais c'est vrai ça me
titillait depuis longtemps j'ai
l'impression que j'ai lâché ma plume
jusqu'à présent j'étais un peu étriqué
veille j'étais coincé parce que je
faisais des biographies ou d où des
documents historiques là pour la
première fois je me suis lâché je me
suis c'est un roman de moeurs il se
passe des choses c'est assez léger non
et je crois avoir trouvé mon style donc
je suis assez je suis assez fier de ce
livre j'ai entendu les gens lire en
hurlant de rire donc ça me c'est même
plutôt vent c'est le début d'un bon
virus surtout pas du tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on veut peut vous
réinviter dans ping pong mais ce sera
signe déraillement mais ce sera avec
plaisir de vous resservir cimade et
merci à tous
[Musique]